[Music]
come on wolverine let's go
eat dirt cyclops x-men don't cut and run
what's up everyone this is disney plus
deets where we break down everything you
need to know about your favorite disney
plus movies and series i'm kenneth and
i'm marcellus and not to do our own
horns but we're pretty much the biggest
disney plus fans out there now let's do
it
that's right let's get into it
twelve-year-old kenneth is excited
today's video is about one of our
favorite superhero shows of all time
x-men the animated series let's take it
all the way back to 1963 when marvel
all-stars jack kirby and stan lee
created the first x-men comic book
originally the characters were teenagers
in identical blue uniforms and their
dialogue was all quips and wisecracks in
1975 marvel decided to reimagine the
x-men as a more international team yes
and you know what kim diversity is key
writer lynn wien and artist dave cockrum
came up with among others wolverine
who's canadian and our favorite
mysteries of the elements from northern
africa storm but this wasn't just a new
team roster it set a whole new tone for
the series the heroes were adult with
real relatable problems and i just love
how they interacted with each other i
wanted to like sit and chill with them
and just talk about stuff going on right
what was the next mission exactly
president of fox kids margaret losh was
an early fan of the comics and thought
the x-men would be perfect for an
animated series so perfect in fact that
lost told her boss if x-men the animated
series doesn't succeed you can fire me
that's commitment putting it all on the
line once the series got the green light
in 1992 marvel and fox agreed to a core
team along with wolverine jubilee and
storm they added cyclops rogue and
gambit professor xavier jean grey and
beast rounded out the squad here we go
who is this it is magneto
one of the best villains of all time on
the count of three say your favorite
x-men character one two three storm
according to creative executive sydney
iwanter it was important to focus on
these characters real emotional
weaknesses well here's the thing they
just weren't typical superhero
vulnerabilities we're talking about
rogue not being able to touch anyone
without consequences absolutely storm
dealing with being orphaned and even
wolverine dealing with unrequited love
oh let's talk about the love triangle oh
my cyclops wolverine and jean grey and
poor wolverine he was supposed to be at
the wedding but he is mad because he is
in love with his frenemies wife jean
grey we all love jean grey i felt like
jean grey was like the glue would always
come in and kind of just make sure she
was the referee for everybody i can
sense his feelings
they seem genuine just like wolverine
that we see right here i used to put
forks between my fingers yes yes i
thought i was the only one i had my
mama's butter knife yeah i was walking
around the house thinking i was wobbling
boy if you don't put my butter knife
back in that drawer i just need pictures
of you in all your makeshift x-men
costumes and we can't forget about my
boy morph he was only supposed to be in
one episode but fox had a focus group
with a couple hundred kids and they
voted for morph as their favorite mutant
resurrected by popular demand the first
season had one continuous storyline but
due to animation delays season two's
episodes were created to stand on their
own so if one episode wasn't finished on
time another could be shown in its place
networks at the time didn't think kids
could follow complicated storylines the
series writing team disagreed which was
definitely the right call and on behalf
of kids everywhere we thank you director
larry houston who was also the very
first black saturday morning storyboard
artist to be hired in hollywood was a
big fan of legendary comic book artist
jim lee lee's x-men costume designs
varied between characters but shared
similar colors and overall style and
therefore inspired the look for the show
we love to see it and speaking of making
some changes in hollywood houston and
show runner eric leewall had a whole new
approach to casting the series the first
batch of audition tapes they received
were all too cartoonish voice actors at
the time weren't used to playing it
straight especially for a saturday
morning cartoon so they ended up
bringing in serious theater actors from
toronto to voice their x-men and these
actors brought a gravitas and a
grounding and a realness to each
character it was just so amazing to hear
it according to george busa who voiced
beast the cast had to record all their
dialogue lines first because their
voices would be so worn out after doing
battle noises like this marcellus oh
[Laughter]
still all that vocal strain paid off
before this cartoon came out we didn't
know how these characters sounded we did
not they were only on paper so this is
the first time for us as fans of the
comic books to actually hear the voice
of our favorite characters and we loved
it the series packed so much story into
22 minutes way more than other animated
shows at the time with 40 page scripts
consisting of 400 to 500 shots it took
more than 30 000 animated frames to make
a single episode totally unheard of for
a kid's cartoon this was way before a
computer animation so every single one
of those frames was painted by hand oh
my hands are crapping up just thinking
about all that painting and what about
the cameos from the other marvel heroes
we got captain america right here it was
already a big deal hello headline news
we got x-men and then you turned around
and we got new people ken i was just
starstruck we have to shout out eric
leewald and julia leewald we found their
book x-men the art and making of the
animated series super helpful when
making this episode if you're a fan of
the series you'll love that book make
sure you check it out and that's our
show for today be sure to like subscribe
and check out x-men the animated series
now streaming on disney bluff take care
of yourselves and the planet and we'll
see you next time marcellus and ken
signing off storm would be both of our
favorite characters that's because we
spend too much time together you love it
i do i do